welcome to the world armwrestling league
it will be
[Music]
this is history
and we welcome you to Los Angeles
California
wal 504 inside of the Robo just across
the street with a Staples Center here in
downtown Los Angeles California tonight
the star is coming out a great turnout
here inside of the noble theater arm
wrestling fans you're in for a treat
tonight tonight's broadcast is brought
to you by Buffalo Wild Wings the
official sports bar of the W Al and our
main event tonight easy money
Dave Chaffee will it be easy money
tonight against Devon no lemon leritz
that's our main event that'll come up in
our fifth match of the night but the
Lassa gets you before that we welcome
you inside of the Novo my name is Ben
Holden great to be joined by the legend
three-time world champion he'll pick up
good to be with you Neal what do you say
about tonight's a night to come back
what a night for strength sports in any
combat sport in any strength sport
people try to manufacture the needle
this needs no manufacturing these guys
tonight in our main event hate each
other
it's been building for months yeah it
nearly boiled over last night tonight's
the night it goes down the talking is
over it's off it's time to put up or
shut up right let's take a look at our
full list of matches on our match card
Neal we'll start things off with a
hometown guy Jamie Sheldon against the
legend Allen Fisher you know you look at
this card talk to bottom and it is
filled with stories we start with a
story
the younger diligent Jim bully against a
man who he's cook from The Legend of
armrest ourself in Allen Fisher
two guys who carry the weight of a
nation on the shoulder in Ryan boy where
ladies matches don't come any bigger
than Marlin Klein Smith and the hammer
hold of fear ASIC we got to heavyweight
standouts the wild horse is back he's
facing a legend and the main event
I'm bristling no wait then he's been
bristling since last night when he was
in the middle of Devin lariat and Dave
Chaffee let's get those of you that are
new to the wal up to speed on the rules
of the game the referee begins the match
by centering the competitors hands on
the table
if they're drips lips will be placed in
the strap during the match
three fouls is a loss all right so those
are the key rules to the game here in
the Wal and Neil let's talk about this
first match Jaime Sheldon he's beaten
Alan Fisher twice the last two times
they've been in fact what's the book on
him and what stands out about Sheldon
you know Jamie Sheldon is an ultra
talented star of the sport this guy's on
the rise he's on the climb he should be
in his absolute prime Alan Fisher
represents an enormous banana-skin for
Sheldon Sheldon is pulling about 63
years of age he should be in the
twilight of his arm wrestling career but
one man doesn't believe that and it's
Alan Fisher yourself Fisher is revved
he's ready he feels like he's reborn
he's just getting started
and he wants to make that starting block
Jamie Sheldon Sheldon told us this
morning he said it's kind of like going
against my dad in that sense 63 against
38 years old yes I mean you look at Alan
Fisher she's been arm wrestling for
longer than Jeff Sheldon has been
breathing this guy was featured in the
Bayeux Tapestry he's been arm wrestling
for every lead the table at the Last
Supper he's cooked from the cloth from
the fiber of armwrestling his hands
they're ridiculous what a webmaster gave
me get around them we'll find out let's
take a look at our tale the tape Neal
and what do you take away from this you
know the most critical thing for me in
this is the start and if you look at the
speed for both men they're dead level
Fisher probably got that explosivity
that powered advantage but you would
think if the match gets into a long
battle it's got a favor Sheldon that
guy's younger he's got that core
strength if you ask my wife how I was
back at 27 I'm sure she heard that
version to the curtain of course
Sheldon's got the youth and in the the
technical department what do you take
away from this anything grab your eyes I
think the big one there obviously the
speed being a level that's gonna be
critical whoever brings it tonight
whoever can land their game first I
think goes on all right very good the
stage is set without further ado let's
get down to our
announcer Justin Roberts for the
introductions time for opening contest a
best-of-five lightweight battle
introducing first competing out of
Riverside California where he is the
founder and CEO of nat fit he sent it
six feet tall and weighed in at 170
pounds with a record of 10 wins and 12
losses he is who natural Jamie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and his children woodwinds and eight
losses he is the most decorated arm
wrestlers of all time winning 26 World
Championships and 40 national titles
through a career that spans three
decades is mr. intensity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
full of energy you told us this morning
he says he feels like he was put on this
earth he's been a little bigger we go
the best-of-five we have 30 seconds in
this Superman showdown series to get a
grip if not you go to the strap Sheldon
loops calm and relaxed Fischer spent 15
of the 30 he did he did indeed Sheldon
because that big hand
65 pounds is just ridiculous 26 world
titles two World Records won four
biggest clubs yeah another four biggest
snowball first poor man August of 1979
referee of course Bart would get some
set wife Jen here we go Neal
really good remover yeah
you ready yeah they both came on yeah
yeah I think Jill was actually a little
edgy there again bought all over it
follow on Jamie Sheldon huge lift on my
elbow from Fisher Nolte there that gives
us a little towel for Jamie you can see
that angle mouth as long as that tracer
round fired early even yeah well that's
illustrating really guys he's just that
nervous energy these guys know exactly
where they are now they know that they
must send at all of the magic
particularly for fishing wasn't about
this to bed there's a warning to to
eighty to eighty thousand REO whoa break
Michelle Michelle that's got it Oh
bangles wonderful armwrestling Jamie the
natural Sheldon we pretty natural you
know what he posted into the cam
beautifully there and as Alan attacked
even with when you see them at the
replay appreciate and raised or for the
least an inch and he'd made no
difference because the Bulls was so
significant he ran right into it let's
see we can see on the replay would
Fisher's elbow now Sheldon stay solid
yeah look at a lift there and it made no
difference because Sheldon had that
pulse and that is gonna put his
confidence barometer through the roof
Jamie Sheldon's statement made so he's
gonna one-nothing lead 90 seconds but
Paul's and Sheldon said 15 years ago the
first Pro he faced was the man he's
facing tonight just trying to get some
lactic acids on up blood the armor
Sheldon let's eavesdrop on Alan Fisher
here
yeah Fisher I need to draw all that
experience not 40 years in the game of
iron arms and he's been here before this
is not his first rodeo but one thing is
evident he has got to change gears he's
got a change strategy he was just
completely our angler he went for the
drive as he went to try and claws that
fork he just run into a brick wall the
pulse was solid and most importantly
there you know everybody was saying that
Alan was the guy with that exclusivity
with that power yeah Sheldon a
one-nothing lead the pin of Alan Fisher
switched sides here I think it's
important to know Jamie Sheldon he's
really maturing as a world-class
arm-wrestle 38 years old he's been in
the game a game this guy's got big wins
on big names as simple as that
Sheldon made two appearances last year
in the Superman showdown series lost
them both
he wanted to strap he got the struck I
was watching intently there just to see
what you wanted this scenario and
explained out exactly how he planned it
now it's up to alum to change that to
create some chaos how does he do that he
does that by changing I lose by changing
setups experience one of the things that
I took away I know you did too from
talking to Jamie Sheldon we talked to
all the competitors before all these
Superman showdown series he said one of
the big things he worked on was the
strap game getting his hand his wrist
right talked a little bit to that well
to be honest the strap is an absolute
weapon when you were pulling a guy
right here he's coding again yes like
Tyson did this is a master class of
positional armwrestling Sheldon all day
in this corner than the respect from
Fisher as soon as he took him down it
was right there he said this is
impressive
honey knows mainly you know Alex a
warrior but he was appreciative of the
fact that this young warm wrestler has
come on Sheldon
he's just looking outstanding yeah you
know sometimes yeah you just very
present and Jimmy Sheldon tonight is
very very you could work knowledge that
this guy is about an hour away from home
in Riverside California as we look back
look at that replay there look at the
way that he maintains his linearity
throughout that obviously much he's not
bumped outside of his shoulder it's
immediate the reaction is absolutely
linear shoulder to wrist to lat the
track all of those things joined up
perfectly and if you look in the corner
of Alan issue he's posture he's looking
around he's got a wild look in his eye
if you look in the corner of Jamie
Sheldon the man looks like he's going
yachting
he's absolutely super relaxed calm he
knows that the man he wanted to arrive
in this armwrestling match came and he
packed a lot of luggage Ben we certainly
did in Sheldon when he started in the
sport trained in Alan Fisher's group so
he learned from one of the all-time best
he's beaten him the last two times
they've met
let me tell you now Alan Fisher will be
thinking this maybe last chance saloon
on his professional career it's bad
things yes the coffee's burning down
when they saw him wrestler tonight it's
not necessary that he's done anything
wrong against the Jamie show that has
done everything right it's been a superb
performance and he's through like a
knife through butter so Sheldon trying
to close it out here
clean sweep but and foul on Jamie
Sheldon there and even when he takes
that far he's relaxed he feels like he's
going up again yeah he's gets what he
needs yep and all that is he's just not
settling the match he's got enough
experience he's got enough presence of
mind right now to allow that match to be
led where he wants it to be
I'm Fisher knows that but there's
nothing he can do about it you know this
is diligence from Sheldon he's Scooby I
said at the beginning
he's textbook he's diligent the way he
approaches the matches is perfect and
tonight is the very best of Jason looks
very good last year in Norfolk lost to
Jeff Hale that super match three two in
the finals lost to Tom Holland and
Atlanta to nothing trying to get what
would be a big big win here as Jamie
Sheldon and close it out here leading to
nothing and it puts fatigue into each
man with a foul
the hair - now what does it mean to this
mom and ellipses all now now children
it's going to be careful he's gonna try
an attack on fish because he's going to
bomb strength and he can apply the power
into the strap
he sure has to put forward and he has to
make sure the children's gone
[Music]
[Applause]
Sheldon was in a dangerous dangerous
position there and he came through with
flying colors exams incredible respect
one of the youngsters making his way up
in the ranks and one of the legends of
the game as we look back at the pin nail
you see there look at the compromised
position of Sheldon's wrist what he does
have there is that strap seal it's
anchoring yes cutting into his wrist
that's where the pressure he's going
it's to the side and back and it's hard
he wants to make sure the fissure can't
ground himself Count Basie's elbow can't
connect from his own shoulder to his
wrist and he prevents alum from doing
that and then drives drives drives he
will not back off and he gets a just
reward for an exceptional performance
I'm so proud of Jimmy Sheldon tonight
California versus California yep and the
torch was passed Los Angeles beat San
Diego and this one and the winner Jamie
Sheldon standing by in the pit with our
own Jason zone Fisher
[Music]
like to hear everyone chanting your name
going up against a legend and coming
away 300 on top here tonight
I've known Allen my whole career this
this win is 15 years in the making so
this means a lot to me
hats off to Allen Fisher 40 years at the
elite level just amazing amazing like
you said Allen Fisher's been doing this
for 40 years an incredible legend in the
sport I can see the respect that you
have for him I mean what what does it
mean to not only beat him but just to
face someone like Allen Fisher well it's
like I told everybody it's like
armwrestling your dad I mean he set the
pace years ago and it's time to pass the
torch and I'm honored to be on a stage
with him how were you able to overcome
his massive hand I shook his hand
earlier today it's the largest hand I've
ever seen in my life well you saw it I
went straight to the strap I mean that
was the last 13 14 years I was
struggling with that giant hand so I had
to go back to basics and learn to use
the strap and it paid off
well we might have seen him just passed
the torch to Jamie Sheldon a rising star
in the sport give it up one more time
congratulations Ben Neal back to you
guys
thanks so much Jason we got a lot more
to come including Ryan Bowen and Alan
Guetta Walla Clyde Smith Bri SiC the two
Swedes will collide Sylvain piranha and
the wild horse Matt masse and you don't
want to miss Dave Chaffee and Devon
Lehren here's what they're saying about
their match said some things disrespect
people he thinks I'm unsportsmanlike
disrespect the referee disrespect all
the arm wrestlers it's just so funny
say that brought up you know for good
sportsmanship apparently they don't
teach that in Canada really really gonna
enjoy cracking his wrist back
great Zambia with us here tonight and
Bleacher at porn live we thank them for
their support and all they do for the
wal our presentation tonight coming to
you from Los Angeles California inside
of the Novo theatre one match down Jamie
Sheldon a three nothing victory against
Alan Fisher and a lot more to come but
before we get to our special guests and
more the matches let's speak a little
wal with referee Mike Fontenot
[Music]
hello everyone my name is Mike Fontenot
with the world almost in league and
we're gonna talk to you today about to
start we have a two-phase start with the
WL or opponents gonna walk up to the
table they're gonna have 30 seconds okay
that I'm gonna assist them in getting a
grip and negotiating a fair start okay
we're gonna come up palm to palm thumbs
up
I'm gonna struck you to close your
thumbs straighten your wrist close your
hands go if they fail to negotiate a
grip and there's too much going on we're
gonna go into phase 2 and introduce the
straps once the straps have been applied
we're gonna close your thumbs straight
and wrists closed hands go and that's
our cadence we use at the WL alright and
through the magic of television Neil
we've got a rather large human in
between us the monster Michael Todd
3-time hammer holder where's the hammer
man you got it with you good to see a
man and you were slated to pull here
things change but you're still here
supporting the the circuit so what do
you what do you been up to lately
man just training but sitting back
enjoying that win I'm super excited
about tonight's card obviously the main
event yeah so yeah I'm just a fan
tonight man it's awesome title
implications make huge ramifications for
these two men both of the guys feel like
they're in that picture to get a shot at
you hammer who comes through I'm gonna
put you on the spot I mean okay so Devin
looks huge he's strong he's versatile
but I just I can't I can't count out the
power Dave Chaffee it's a slight
favorite Dave Chaffee in my opinion I do
wonder whether Dave's looking at how you
and Devin went and the fact that he
pushed you harder than Dave was able to
himself do you think that's gonna play
in his mind a little bit Mike or no
honestly I don't think so um everyone
knew going in that match I was the most
repaired strongest I'd ever been so I
wasn't the same guy when I pulled Dave
that I wasn't up for Devin last year and
Devin's probably not either I don't know
man this is a match I've been wanting to
see too
amazing Athletes two guys top of the top
of the heap and I'm ready to see who
comes through to lose to me in the
finals apex predators for sure remain
and one thing I'll say about this we've
spoken many times
Dave chief he's like a human biscuit
super nice super respectful not tonight
brother what last night you two are in
there I was gonna ask Michael about that
my god what's going through your mind
when you're watching Neil in between Oh
Dave pull these guys apart because I'm
on strike will you beat them both yeah
yeah it was awesome dude crazy night
crazy yeah I'm super excited like I said
I couldn't be any more excited I'm also
super stoked about August 4th yes
Buffalo Wow yes Fort Worth I'm actually
gonna be the host of the event come on
out meet the monster get an autograph
and it's free registration go online and
register register uh they say
everything's bigger in Texas so let's
make this the biggest one yet yes you're
licked off in Wisconsin Scranton and
then you got the one in Fort Worth and
you've also got one coming up in
Manchester New Hampshire as well on the
Buffalo Wild Wings to her monster thanks
for joining us thanks for having good
senior brother Michael Todd and coming
up next it'll be Ryan Bowen the Aussie
in town to take on the man for Mexico
Ellen get up that's coming your way
momentarily and Neil let's take a look
at the tale the tape between these two
guys when you take away from this you
know wolf
I actually don't think pay too much
attention to the tail of the team to the
stats to the physical he doesn't matter
this is mental this is about two men who
are carrying the weights of a nation on
their shoulders Brian Blubaugh and this
is a childhood dream for that man he
wants this so bad and his improvements
in the sport have just been exponential
incredible rate of improvement he's been
training with the best guys in the world
Allen Guerra I'm not sure there is a
more dedicated more focused individual
in the sport all right
so earlier today we caught up for the
Australian and he's confident and he's
ready for his wal debut I've seen Allen
I've sized him up everything about the
man to me smells like a victory for me
I'm ready to get this on
such a social media presence this guy is
so well known one thing I can say is the
Allen Guerra wants this so back he
brought down in his fears with emotion
today such as his desire this is a mano
embodies the warrior spirit of the
Mexican people he is prepared to go out
on his shield like never before he feels
disappointed that he lost to Michael
Cyrus he feels this is a shot to redeem
himself what a match this could be them
yeah last selling Harris last year here
in Los Angeles 3 nothing and you can say
the same about that country pride for
Ryan Bowen being an Australian champion
Oceania champion these guys are cut from
the same cloth in terms of what they
came here to do and I'm gonna go out on
a limb and say this could be the best
night for both men in their career it
could be the best match on this court he
is the expert folks let's get down to
our pit announcer Justin Roberts for the
introductions for this match this
contest is a best-of-five middleweight
battle introduce you to the table first
competing out of Brisbane Australia he
was a member of the Australian Army and
now produces and hosts an arm wrestling
podcast he says that six feet a one inch
tall and weighed in at an even 200
pounds making his debut in a world arm
wrestling league one of the best pullers
in Australia Ryan
[Applause]
come on and his opponent his robotics
engineer competing out of Monterrey
Nuevo Leon Mexico standing at 5 feet 11
inches tall and weighing in at 200
pounds with a record of 18 wins and
here's one of the young guns of the wal
who is really shaking things up his Lu
war machine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now the wal money in a wall
both these guys look like they are ready
to explode the emotion is flowing over
and I'll tell you what I expected that
more from Alan Guerra Brian Bowan he's
got to be careful here that he did some
looking at Guerra now and Alan seems to
have turn the corner and that could
illustrate the both you give me an open
palm I'll go this way a little bit
towards Alan please
come with me and with close your thumbs
stay right here
[Music]
both are
[Music]
to imagine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm good I'm good yeah get his wife his
mom and his brother here john brzenk
there in the corner of Ryan
[Music]
[Music]
it obviously means a ton de Bohun as
well very very much maybe a little
around pressing on you can see his
confidence growing he feels like he's
the man with the power what I will say
is that Brian Bowan cooked a lot awake
for this much only a couple of days ago
he was 215 pounds he came to 200 pounds
for the weight cook can take at all he's
flown across the world 30 hours in the
air yeah unbelievable journey yeah this
is a learning experience for him but
he's a very well-rounded recipe just
needs to settle himself spent seven
years in the Australian Army as an
officer
Ryan Bowen trailing in this best-of-five
in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's giving me something rich
to then recover you perhaps beetles arm
strength don't remember Guerra
talking this much last year he is really
[Applause]
he can't help he's not thinking about my
right he just feels like he's arrived
the adrenaline just takes over right it
does indeed
let's see how children Sangster Ryan
listen I did would I need water any
water and as I said after we lost the
first many people have done that too
right
but Ryan has got a lot of options he's a
very very good arm-wrestle john brzenk
they're working on his right this man
stood on the shoulders of giants
but he's still reaching for the moon he
doesn't think he's finished it's part of
a master plan he's trying to create a
better the best version of himself let's
go back and take a peek here at the the
end of this and the win for Boeing look
at that he's adjusting over the hand and
wrist and then he transitions to the
press he's already done the hard work
they're really pivotal is that Allan
Vera lost his wrist in hand early what'd
she do that I'm not sure where he can
recover it john brzenk
former WL champion and arm wrestling
royalty that's what i'll call get his
corner ah now we know about the heart
if you ever need it see the test of
exactly how for I'm not carry this young
man yeah I'm about to find a are you
said to me last night when we first sat
down with Jason and all of our crew you
said I wrote it down right you said this
very well could be the best match of the
night it's 1:1 now because these men the
stakes couldn't be higher if they were
fighting for the title in this division
yeah Alan Greta feels like this is one
of his last opportunities to impress he
feels like he has to perform from Mexico
Ryan Bowen secular than that one game
but he's never got the recognition that
he deserves one one third fall is gone
at least four we know that pull your
thread Cohen's gonna target the hand and
wrist again we're not will like it that
the strap goes on because he needs that
look where ya trying to get some lactic
acid out of that that's being poor back
in and bones calling him out yes already
trying to just start that bumped up your
mental games he based a lot of his style
on Devon lot higher low and you see that
similarity yeah you compare the two so
they dreamed of this chance Bowen did
since he was a youngster and he first
learned of armwrestling
now he's on the stage here in the wal
against
creating that he's targeting because he
knows now he has the opportunity to base
himself Rambo and so you know
[Applause]
and Ryan bones good he's looking at the
crowd he's smiling isn't true he's gotta
go to the back the theatre's won't
finish this it's there
he's up tension
[Applause]
[Music]
two fractions with the seriously go
to try to put their bullets into him its
new hero on bowels keep pulling keep
pulling two fouls on arrow Alain Delon
[Music]
boy he's gaining leverage all the time
would you think to take your hand
[Applause]
[Music]
already two one right bolos it out after
a 90 second break for both men here Neil
[Music]
may be all she wrote from he's in that
situation now where he's desperate he's
poaching at straws and Brian Bowan has
done his homework here in those last two
rounds and he's put some serious damage
that disables the arm strength Neutron
there on that like the hands of Platt so
but I feel like hit and then I'm gonna
transition to a first quick
vanish right up you can try to get it
into a dormant position brzenk agrees in
you do too right young % yeah I actually
expected that I mean Ryan really now
he's starting to feel the burn in his
arm he knows that Allen Berra is still
dangerous yes on arm strength but he's
got no chance in the Homburg wrist
ryan is all over the hand and wrist he's
gonna make that stick now he's got to
take that I vantage grab it by the
scruff of the neck and finish it dried
it home and he realized he's that he
doesn't want to get into a situation
where he loses all the pieces that are
all I would even touch all this arm
wrestling
[Music]
come on like that mindset good
instructing them they've got ten seconds
to get back to the table for round
number four they switch sides and Bowen
will try and close it out here in his
wal debut you know he's gonna try and
blast the wrist and then transition
quick for the press I don't expect he'll
have a trouble any trouble at all
getting there getting that risk round
yeah SWAT stuff yeah Bowen said to him
he said you want to strap and time ran
out Bart wood says all right it's time
to strap up well it's actually going to
help the situation because what he needs
to be careful of is that he doesn't get
outside his own shoulder trying to drive
to the side he's got to keep that back
pressure constant he's got to make sure
the Allens wrist and hand are totally
broken back and sacrificed before he
moves on the show because you get the
feeling that last chance saloon Allen's
gonna go hard to decide any and he
almost expose Ryan earlier with them
very similar move Bowen trying to close
this out in three one
Jamie Sheldon won the opening match of
the night defeating Alan Fisher three
nothing still to come our main event
Dave Chaffee and Devan Larry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he wanted to make a career of
armwrestling this was his opportunity he
grabbed it with poor pounds the mountain
down on the way walks us through it when
he was in his corner there any control
look at a transition there dives in
drives down talking to him there but he
cannot stop the inevitable and from
there who born on top with the shawl
that finishes the match and puts the
flag of Australia on the map of world
armwrestling league picture says it all
and the winners with Jason's own Fischer
Jason Ryan one wal WD beyou for you here
tonight unbelievable tell me what you're
feeling right now the greatest moment is
my sporting life nothing beats this it's
incredible you are a champion of the
sport back in Australia where you from
not a lot of people know you had to lose
15 pounds to make weight you were sick
yesterday you had every excuse possible
not to compete at the highest level but
how are you able to do what you just did
here on the table with an absolutely
amazing amount of support from so many
people at home my kids are watching
hello brother
my parents look there's so much support
the team with people behind me the crowd
it's unbelievable I can't thank anyone
enough now you often lose early and are
able to adjust and come back and that's
exactly what happened here tonight is
that a strategy is this a style how are
you able to do that you know I wouldn't
call it a stall or strategies just the
way it pans out I I'm someone who I'm an
adaptive arm wrestler I like to feel
what's going on and then adjust and
thanks to people like John bruising in
the corner they did the adjustments he
just gave me trust me having Johnny in
the corner has every arm wrestle in this
room could appreciate changes things so
john brzenk is absolutely one of the
greatest to ever do it in your corner
well you are such a champion of the
sport you host a popular podcast you're
all over social media you've trained so
hard what does the sport of arm
wrestling mean to you this is the
fulfillment of a childhood dream I
always wanted to be a professional
sportsman so to do it on the best stage
on the planet for the wal couldn't be
happier and there's more to come there's
more to come for sure there's I want to
say this one man in particular that
means a lot to me I treasure the man
dearly and I'm wrestling but I need to
square the ledger
Justin Bishop you'll be next all right
he's calling them out can't wait to see
it that's right Justin Bishop you heard
that congratulations Ryan that flight
back to Australia is gonna be a lot more
fun been back to thank you Jason and
in alexander's City Alabama you know the
pull heard that tonight
still to come all inclined Smith and fee
are Isaac the two Suites two of the best
women in the world Sylvain Ferran and
fat fast and we've got Devin Larry and
Dave Chaffee coming up in our main
events as Ryan Bowen is wal debut a
winner and ballin Kleinschmidt she'll
make her wal debut that's coming up next
here on be our live
you
we're back here in Los Angeles
California we're inside of the novo
right across the street from the Staples
Center alongside the former three-time
world champ
kneel pick up my name is Ben Holden
great to have you with us here tonight
and tonight's broadcast is brought to
you by Buffalo Wild Wings the official
sports bar of the W al
and we want to tell you more about
Buffalo Wild Wings and our involvement
with them the first of four wal open
events was held the Buffalo Wild Wings
in Madison Wisconsin this past weekend
the turnout was spectacular like to say
thanks to Steve South worst and
Wisconsin armwrestling and wal Zone Tony
Kent aus key who did an amazing job of
the tournament
these events are totally free and open
to everyone for first-timers
seasoned pros children youth men and
women there are three events remaining
in Scranton Manchester New Hampshire and
Fort Worth Texas go to Wal underground
calm / open to register for the event
near you
[Music]
this is a sport for everybody
[Music]
so great to see Neil the sport continue
to grow with all those events going on
through the help of Buffalo Wild Wings
as well in the wao 100% this is a
situation where we're breeding tell them
through that showcase it's good to see
let's beat our referee crew up close and
personal we'll take a look at Bart wood
of course the better in our head referee
tonight and little step out of the way
there and Bart will reveal his wife Jen
would you're the better-looking one bang
I'm yeah no question and then Frank
being our good friend he's our video
referee here tonight so our officiating
crew they worked the table and keep
everything intact and you know
let's get backstage Jason's own Fisher
with a special guest Jason huge match
tonight against Dave how excited are you
for this match your Owen two against
Dave a lots changed since then but how
you feeling I feel fantastic this is one
of those matches in my career that's
it's like defining Dave Chaffee is one
of those dudes in the sport that's
recognized globally I'm one step closer
that pinnacle big big night it's a
really big night now there's been a lot
of talk between the two of you guys he
says that you're disrespectful to your
opponents you're disrespectful to the
sport you say that he has no heart is
that bad blood and animosity gonna carry
over to the table yeah yeah you know if
Dave wants to fight me I mean you know
we can probably do it on the table but
you know hopefully Bart can keep that
monkey away from me after I crack his
wrist back cuz all those things that he
you know says that I am well I'm gonna
be all those things and more if if fate
allows me are you gonna try to get under
his skin tonight once you get out there
that's the only thing I want to do you
know winning losing I want to win in the
way that will piss him off the most yeah
it's certainly gonna be entertaining and
I'll let you get focused and get in the
zone I can't wait to see this match good
luck tonight then can't wait Dave I hope
you're ready for some unit humiliation
that's the word I'm looking for all
right Ben Neal back to you guys thanks
so much Jason and we appreciate them and
leritz top of mind I mean this has been
going on since the last event we had in
Richmond back in June most interesting
to me about this is that Dave Chaffee is
not the guy you you ever draw out he's
not the guy that engages in this talk he
just wants to go out there and let his
arm wrestling do the talking this is a
different day of Chafee yeah Dave chafe
is emotional he's involved in this match
in a big way he wants to rip Devon's
head off but Chafee losing in the last
event to the monster Michael Todd the
hammer was on the line and let's now
shift our attention to what's coming up
next here and that is our women's
division match and you've got Malin
Klein Smith world champ and fear Isaac
the debut for Klein Smith in the wal as
well that could play into this couldn't
it tonight
her debut here it really cooled I mean
what really matters here is which
Marling client Smith shows up is she
gonna be a little nervous is she gonna
be a little hesitant she's not been in
the world arm wrestling league before
she's got to make some adjustments she's
facing the lady were looking at now fear
ASIC is the title holder and she has had
no equal she's not being tested to date
I think she's gonna get tested tonight
and she knows exactly what she's facing
Marlin Klein Smith is certainly her
equal this is a very exciting match two
of the best may be the two best in the
world we've seen fear Rancic here on the
wal circuit now for the last few years
what do you say we go over to Sweden
Neal and get to know her a little better
look to me my name is fear racing and
I'm from Sweden
there is the village where I grew up I
love student mom
it's special because it's just my
relatives here and this is the house
where I grew up
my mother and father's house this is my
mother yeah she's my hardest critic she
say but you can't win if you don't train
now it's your fault so I love come home
and train with the school my father was
the trainer we have 40 to 50 people here
training hard it's in the heart the
brain the biggest carbon Sweden
who have round 20 world champions their
main purpose is to become an investor
good quality the studio man is like
armwrestling mecca in Sweden my best
training partner here is high down the
Sun can be a night I've been training
since we started when I started I was 11
and I was 7 high they have won like 11
world champion titles man she is my
custom tube here we have our gym outside
the playground gym this have definitely
have been a part of the success
I have to do this I want to win we tried
other sports too but we are really sucks
every other sports
alright and without further ado let's
get down to our pit announcer Justin
Roberts for the introductions and this
women's match is a best-of-five match in
the wal women's middleweight division
introducing first a service center
manager competing out of the mecca of
women's arm wrestling Stockholm Sweden
standing at five feet seven inches tall
and weighing 154 pounds
she is Malin Klein's man
and her opponent a prop maker competing
out of n Sam Heaton Sweden she says it
five feet seven inches tall and weighed
in at 153 pounds she is the current and
undefeated wal middleweight champion she
is via racing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
two Swedes come out Neil and you not
both these women very well they told us
this morning
Theoden she said the first time they
pulled she was 12 years old when Smith
was 16 so this goes back a long ways
these ladies represent the pinnacle of
female armwrestling and it's exciting to
have the very very best here fear has
not been challenged to date really she's
run through all our opponents a massive
challenge in the form of mauling
Kleinschmidt it's the primary weapon Wow
both of them yeah clang Smith blew
through the hand and wrist there now
we're going to the strap this usually
would favor fee racing racing is a
master of the hand and wrist and she
will try to close down the space but one
very very interesting factor here is
that Marlon Cline Smith has a lot more
room to move into she can move further
back than she's used to she's got nine
inches of pad to play with if she can
connect with her shoulder on my initial
hit it may make a huge difference and I
cannot wait to find out look at a
composer on the face first Paul this
best-of-five with the win it's all now
what a way to announce yourself yes some
wrestling league been Holden what do you
feel that's what a debut indeed world
champion and for those that don't know
it was mauling that took fie arising out
in that championship match as we look
back at the pin here now look at the
replay and she decimated the rest a fear
Isaac the expulsion T of mauling Klein
Smith there is a new girl in town and a
name
Klein Smith Ben the Swedes brought their
best these girls best on the table on
the table
not so much wow what a start do not make
the mistake of thinking that fear ASIC
however is out of this armwrestling
match look at the face 3-time hammer
holder in 18:1 both hands and 16 she
needs to find that different angle but
of critical importance here was that
speed that killer star Ryan Boyd there
he made his debut now he's watching
Malin Klein Smith make her debut and
she's got a one nothing lead in the
best-of-five intensity coming off these
ladies unbelievable look at the speed
from both these girls the acceleration
learn a lesson here look who's on this
compromise I think it's ray six and it
was flying Smith knew it she roared
across the table she doesn't like the
strap but of that explosivity allow her
to gain the media looks in a much better
position she's rising hard and this is a
pivotal round for her now she must put
the brakes on and put them on early foul
on fear Isaac yeah little too early
there but I'll tell you what
it didn't matter here Marlene's wrists
was rock strong Marlon looking ready
look at that
bawling-crying Smith he's running
through the lasik she's running her over
then even Bart wood said Wow impressive
Neal incredibly impressive we thought
Alan Fisher would bring the intensity
Holy Smoke look at that again on the
replay and look at the reaction at the
end of the match drives down smashes
into the pot and then she comes up and
absolutely explodes big drive but that
wrist and hand fear with every fiber of
her being trying to put the brakes on
there but not an opportunity to do it
because now clients myth us two inches
more to move in - yeah she can utilize
that space she's been practicing
intensely on the bigger pad so 90
seconds between Paul's down to 40 now
rice Thicke has to find a way to come up
with a W here Klein Smith will make it a
clean sweep
Jamie Sheldon won our first match and a
clean sweep look at a shake in the hand
and wrist or fear and Isaac his damage
band she's hurt yeah that hand and wrist
is in pain she's talking to jake Smith
the rock star down there and she's
shaking her hand and wrist furiously
trying to keep calm trying to take in
the breaths but it's hard to see a way
back into this match unless she moves
much deeper into the grip and I don't
think she can do that because by doing
so she allows
but unity to reach the pinnacle speed so
here we go a chance for Klein Smith and
her wal debut nail to make it a clean
sweep could finish next without the
strap I would not be surprised if she
finishes dish without a strap unless via
dumps this total I'm controlling from
racing no way she's losing her hand and
wrist today unless she does something
catastrophic ly wrong she looks ready
and this is an incredible performance
bike what a way to start what a dream
incredible
and one of the things she said Klein
Smith did this morning was she said I
don't know where I'm gonna be on my
body's on 6 a.m. time back in Sweden
doesn't look like it it looks like the
alarm clock went off just fine for yes
it does make that looked perfectly
adjusted and she's very very awake yes
close this out I think she will Oh total
destruction she's got it again it's over
with and you know what they're speaking
to each other there but here ASIC just
said hey fair enough no chunks yeah
you're definitely too strong for me she
said you're the champ
you aren't the girl on this light sue
eyes and her wal debut Maulik client
smith comes away with a cast from Bart
wood and she comes away with a sweep of
her fellow countrywoman fear Isaac all
about [ __ ] wrist all about my hand
and wrist and she capitalized on it from
there there was no way back and she
aggressively toward to the pad
master class from mauling Kleinschmidt
so in back-to-back matches first time in
the wal we had Ryan Bowen now we've got
Mallen Klein Smith she's standing by
with Jason's own fish
Mahlon another incredible wal w at a
beauty r tonight that was incredible
what did you say to fiha right after the
match I know you two were so close what
words were exchanged that I couldn't
like just please the third match because
I was so on fire so I said I'm sorry
you apologized no apologies necessary
what you did tonight was incredible this
was your first match here in the wal now
you first you did something that no one
here has done via race ik was undefeated
in world armwrestling league and you
just defeated her three Oh what does
this victory mean for you here tonight
it means so much for me because at the
WAAF I won the world's I didn't get to
meet fee and everybody said like she's
the best and we didn't meet each other
and so yeah it means a lot to prove that
I earn to be the world champion it was a
remarkable performance here tonight
you've known feeis since you were you
grew up with her in Sweden I think you
first pulled against her when you were
16 years old what does it mean to have
your debut here at the wal against your
good friend Thea racing
I loved it he has been there such a
support I know that she was not she said
earlier that she was really tired she
couldn't fire up for the game I feel
sorry for her but I could so it was my
day today but I know that she's so super
strong and I needed just to somebody
said that you couldn't you couldn't have
a fast start like explosive beauty in
this wal so I wanted to show him Neil
pickup that you can be explosive
all right well Neil I'll give you a
chance to respond and I'll give you a
chance to celebrate congratulations an
amazing debut and the first of many here
at the wal nil any rebuttal to that you
know none none whatsoever I come
congratulate Mallen and off she came the
pressure was on her she came in here
with an enormous name an enormous
pedigree an enormous reputation and it
was all on the line in unfamiliar
territory she isn't used to the world
armwrestling league right and she looked
like she'd been here forever bent so
back-to-back newcomers to the wal come
away with wins
still to come another newcomer to the
wal Sylvain Perron will take on the wild
horse mat mask and then the main event
Chaffee and Larrick there's piranhas
backstage getting warmed up getting his
mind right that matches coming up next
here from LA
Oh
craziest thing I've ever seen in a match
I seen a lot of crazy things broken arms
arm breaking multiple number of broken
arms before just hearing that snout it
wasn't nice
besides the broken arms explode like
with blood just pass out boom dude hit
the ground he just passed out mat mask
broke his finger like that 7-minute
Gerry cataract match Gerry cataract in
Michael Todd I'll be biased
it was grazing scene I don't think I've
ever seen one that long before there's
so much coming down for my face and it's
going to my eyes so I'm trying to think
like you know they don't want to lose
for nothing seven minutes to get a
restart and press the hell out of me
that's in same but got me here I got a
question for Neil when we get to it in a
moment on that we're back here at the
Noble in Los Angeles California three
matches in we got the next one coming up
between matt mask and Sylvain Perron and
now let's take a look back at the
highlights the moving pictures the key
ones starting with our first match you
know what this was all about Jamie
shoulders not your mum put on an
absolute
Masterclass California versus California
the torch was passed Sheldon took over
he is the new statesman of California
yes in our second match Brian Bowen
wanted this match so badly he wanted to
make a good impression
he did it in dramatic fashion he was
tested early he looked like he was in
serious trouble but he came back he
reinvented himself his whole career has
been around evolution we saw him in Bowl
as a world armwrestling league caller
tonight the next chapter has begun for
the Australia and then in match number
three the two Swedes and mauling Klein
Smith arrived like no one has ever
arrived she decimated a former champion
an undefeated champion and she blew
through her like a hurricane she really
did it
we walked it back to our office for the
night van Holden three-time world
champion ile pick up and heal before we
move on any further I just want to hear
the craziest thing you've seen as we
heard from so many of the great wall
competitors what's the craziest thing
you've seen on an arm wrestling table in
your career I've seen a lot of crazy
things on an arm wrestling table but
what I will say is I want to draw on the
jury cataract thing he said unbelievable
much yeah a lot in it just and let's
link that let's tie that into what we're
gonna see tonight Dave Chaffee Devin
Lara yeah enormous encounter in terms of
its importance a man watching in the
wings is that month
Jerry Cala ret he will go in the next
event yes in Tulsa
he faces Todd Hutchins and that is also
critically important will we see another
7 8 minute match who knows who knows
we'll find out in less than a month
let's get our tale the tape on our next
match here Neal and it's the lumberjack
in the wild horse old Quran from
Sherbrooke Quebec so Eastern Canada mat
mask from red here Western Canada his
these two go head-to-head and you see
the particulars on both men you know
what the smart money is on that match
the wild horse is there now he's the
prison he's the man of the moment and
he's got explosivity that will match
anyone in the game
he is facing among who has already
carved his legacy out of solid rock yeah
so then piranhas beaten everyone there
is to beat this is a man that beat John
Burris Inc in chrysella 440 crown he's
got an incredible pedigree he's a really
slippery character
it's defense against attack Parral all
defense masks all attack and Matt wants
to come back for me not like not matte
mask like performance in the last event
in Richmond - yeah he does a lot of
pressure on my it's a bit of ropey start
this year but I got to say it seemed to
me like he was reinvigorated he's been
bouncing around out there yeah yeah
that's him earlier today and he looked
like he was in a really good place he
told us he wanted to emulate what we've
just seen from Klein Smith he wanted to
be all business no-nonsense he didn't
want to get into long battles he
particularly doesn't want to get into a
long battle with someone like Perron he
wants to put him to the sword finish
quickly you look at the stat yeah and
basically it's weighted all defense in
the side of firaon all attack on the
side of mask 9.2 on the top roll the hit
nine point four that spells an attacking
arm wrestler there's no one better than
mask no question about it
Sylvain Perron no stranger to arm
wrestling we mentioned he's new to the
wal and we talked to Matt mask earlier
today about that and what he knows about
his opponent
Pollan Sylvain peril fellow Canadian
many of you don't know so there has been
a huge huge lead in the sport
inspiration for many of us Canadians of
growing up into it
15 10 even up to five years ago he was
definitely one of the meant to be he's
kind of taking a little break he's
working his way back kind of feel bad
for him I'm gonna be his first match
back but it is what it is let's see what
he's got bringing forth so all right the
pride of Red Deer Alberta Matt mast
there let's get to our pin announcer
Justin Roberts for the introductions of
these two men is a best-of fun match in
the Wal heavyweight division introducing
to the table first a forestry contractor
competing out of Sherbrooke Quebec
Canada sending at 5 feet 11 inches tall
and weighing in at 255 pounds
making his return to the pro arm
wrestling circuit this is the Jack
Sylvane
[Applause]
and his opponent an oil rig field
specialist competing out of Red Deer
Alberta Canada standing six feet five
inches tall and waiting to 142 pounds
with a record of 31 wins and 14 losses
he made huge strides last year and is
one of the most exciting arm wrestlers
on the circuit
ladies and gentlemen this is a while of
course Matt max
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go mutt mask returns and you
concerns a very different look on the
face of the wild horse he is facing a
mom who's a debutante here but he's
shrouded in mystery as to where his
former stands a mask well it's been a
night for the debutantes one of them in
his corner Ryan Bowen yep but I'll tell
you what it is he wants to reverse that
trend and he wants to become world
armwrestling league's old guard he's
eyeing him out mask was wiser just
eyeing him down the two Canadians lock
up utilizing that side pressure but it's
funny time one for a map mask until you
felt what Matt moscow's and that looked
ominous for me that's all over his
address and look he felt something there
so Bain big drive so when stops it
drives to the side Oh last with the win
he sits for a second and a third hit
wild horse Matt last an acceleration he
said he wanted to do a mall incline
Smith yep he's off to a good start isn't
he just quick worked for masks in the
opening round for a one-nothing lead so
90 seconds between poles and maskers
just ironed down roll on caged tiger I
can tell you one thing Sylvain Peron
needs and the strap he really needs it
nothing look at this on the replay with
a little seeing the end of the match
there but of greater importance was the
start immediately exposed Sylvain's hand
and wrist intensity yes he wants it bats
and I feels like he needs to get back on
the rail yeah he does
disappointed with his performance in
Baltimore against Todd Zilla Todd
Hutchings
talking to him yesterday I said what he
been up to man he said I've been up my
cabin then doing some logging I think
we're gonna get his mind right as we
look back here Neil see well this is the
important element there watch this boom
there goes the hand and wrist and that
enormous Drive the work is done there
and at that point is just re settling
himself
looking to get away without a foul there
and look like it drives down ticks the
pin and you know what that sets the tone
for the match and now he knows he can
expose that hand and wrist I expect to
see Matt a little more settled in this
second round for Peron
he needs the strap and he needs it now
one-nothing lead from at mass best of
532 grip up or what gets upset he's got
the upper body of a super heavyweight
he's got the legs of a duel he won't
deny that either Pirone you know he's
white as a bone duel
yes it's a big young lad but he's giving
away so much leverage now I talked about
the strap maybe making a difference
right we're about to find out we are
what he needs to do unfortunately I
missed it I've talked to over that but
what I was looking up there was matt is
trying to make sure he maintains that
separation because he knows he felt
enough power from Sylvain to know that
if so then can stop
yeah they're bringing max Accenture
there James bringing it to us if you
cheat you trying and throw down there
now silvera
knows that he needs to stop it much
higher than he did last time he's got it
[Music]
closer come stay right here there's the
[Applause]
line from Moscow I love the sport wow
the silver Tong couple a year of Red
Deer look at that again chuck it smoking
early man blasted the hands and wrists
look at the lever shouting up the crowd
there look at the reaction he just about
did flip him over his left leg was three
feet in the air
it's hard to train for somebody like my
heart
yeah and when this kid comes ready he is
just a wrecking crew
he's just talking to himself just pacing
a little bit staring downpour on he said
mehran told us this morning he said he'd
only trained for a couple of months here
mask there I came for one reason and one
reason only he is enjoying his day he's
enjoying getting back to winning ways
yes this mount feels like he was on an
upward trajectory right he feels like he
hits a road bump with topical ginseng
yeah Hutchins threw him out of his
stride and Matt took it to heart he's
dwelt on that he was upset with
everything he's he's aggressive he's
saying he wants to go now it is a by
contrast you look at Sylvain Ferran and
he has a new level of respect from Matt
mask dial bouncing off the walls he's
looking to close without his mat mass
leading to nothing no oh he's hurt so
vain so vain he's hurt he's conceded and
he's hurt he's off so mask a clean sweep
you know I thought so baby bastard yeah
you can see he set up torn something
yeah right there boy went over and he
said you okay he said no I've torn
something yep that's why he was jumped
over the table to try and regain he's
finishing behind the arm yeah such was
the ferocity of my sense that he tore
the shoulder of Sylvain parole so Matt
mast wins it in a sweep Sylvain Ferran
injured here in the end the right
shoulder and
and nothing to see in the last month I'm
not contestant also been per on I just
hope he's not suffered any serious
damage there Jason Fisher in the zone as
always with a victorious Matt mask
Matt mask I mean no one brings an energy
like you where does this come from this
passion that you get when you're on the
table they just got a dig deep deep down
I all I've been thinking about is the
work everything I've been putting into
this for the last seven years I'm not
about left somebody to come in and take
Kenny a little bit of my Thunder I've
had a little bit of hiccups along the
way but my head's right now so let's
keep them coming
what does this win mean to you're coming
off a loss against Todd Zilla Todd
Hutchins when we last saw you to get
back on a winning side a winning streak
how big is this for you for me this was
everything I honestly I felt that my
whole WL career was gonna rely on this
match so I was I was making sure I was
coming out with everything I had so I
ain't hold nothing back you definitely
don't hold anything back Sylvain Peron
is a great competitor What did he say to
you at the end there you guys exchanged
words to get out of a lot of respect for
each other I've got nothing but respect
for the man he's been an inspiration to
me for the last 15 20 years he just told
me right now he's I'm too strong for him
and I think that tape will tell the tale
right so he just honestly he's anybody
that knows anything about armwrestling
that's followed it for more than the
last five years he's probably one of the
biggest names to ever come out of Canada
I've wanted to always grip up with him
pretty much since to begin and just to
test myself to see where I'm at I'm just
wishing it was a better version of him
we had here today so well you definitely
brought your a-game you brought your
best congratulations Matt mask
we got one match left tonight it's the
big one I can't wait this crowd can't
wait Ben and Neil you guys can't wait
let's get loud let's set it back to the
table we are ready to go you got Dave
easy-money Chaffee and No Limits
Devin lair at our main event as you look
back one more time Matt
a clean sweep 3-nothing went for him in
our fourth match of the night the main
events coming up next Neil pickup we've
been waiting for this one for a few
weeks now it's coming our way
we've huffed the stall turbine this is
the main course this is what everybody
came to see I know it's gonna deliver
the first at 4:00 wal open events was
held at the Buffalo Wild Wings in
Madison Wisconsin this past weekend the
turnout was great and a special thanks
goes out to Steve Southworth and
Wisconsin armwrestling in wal zone
Tony katulski who did an amazing job of
the tournament these events are totally
free and open to everyone from first
timers to seasoned pros children youth
men and women there are three events
remaining in Scranton Pennsylvania
Manchester New Hampshire and Fort Worth
Texas so go to wal Underground calm /
open to register for the event near you
[Music]
this is a sport for everybody
[Music]
the event is free and open to everyone
so check it out it's great fun win some
cool awards plus you can meet a lot of
great people in person again register at
Wal underground comm slash open and
let's get down to Jason zone Fisher with
a special guest I'm here with the
current super heavyweight wal champion
monster Michael Todd in the crowd
tonight and he brought his hammer now
Michael you have faced both of these
guys in this and s next match Devin
Larry and Dave Chaffee what is it gonna
take for each guy to win what will be
the difference here tonight Dave Chaffee
is just gonna have to put his power down
quickly get the match out of the way if
Devin wants to win he's gonna have to
make a war out it he's gonna have to
bleed Dave and get him in the later
rounds but like I said in the last
interview I'll take this thing
everywhere you know so I'm just hanging
out with my hammer waiting to find out
who comes up next I've never seen you so
relaxed you were just having a great
time here in LA no match tonight you got
your hammer you're feeling good all
right you faced these guys we you know
them well any predictions who is gonna
take this next match I predict an
amazing match and I can't wait to see it
all right well there's a good chance
we'll see who takes you on in Atlanta
for the hammer the championship in
September gear up good luck and we got a
big match right now
we'll see who might be facing them I
don't know Ben Neil let's do this let's
do this
Thank You Jason welcome up to our office
and he'll pick up the three time world
champ been holdin so good to be with you
here on be our live tonight well we've
waited for this for the last couple of
days since we've all been here Neil you
were in the middle of both men last
night there was all kinds of
conversation there's a lot of things
going on in there what are your thoughts
as we get ready to see this these two
combatants go at it for me personally as
a fan of the sport of armrest and this
is one match that I cannot wait to see
there's so much natural intensity the
stakes are so high for these men both of
these guys want to be their mom they
want that shot of the hammer if they
lose this they drop way down the pecking
order its disaster Nick
afford to lose and I think they're gonna
go out on the shield yeah it's gonna be
a lot of fun to watch as we take a look
at the tale of the tape Neal pick up I
know these aren't exactly things you can
take a lot away from but is there
anything here you take anything away
from I think there's a couple of things
firstly if we look at the weight this is
a gigantic No Limits Devon Lara
he's 268 pounds this guy's got
confidence from that sighs he's
bristling with confidence yesterday he
said everything about me Neal he's
physically impressive I said not
everything mate your legs aren't too
impressive he said which one of the
three you know this guy is a very very
powerful arm wrestler but much more than
that he's a technician he's a thinker
he's a guy with a lot of options Dave
Chaffee is a dragster he's that guy that
has more power than anybody else
armwrestling
is a strength sport and this man is the
strongest
coming off a three nothing defeat but
against monster michael Tadas jason
fisher just chatted with the monster
about that in his laugh
showing so that to come back from
obviously all the talk that's going on
between these two the dislike but
whatever you want to call it but there
are the particulars in terms of the
technical numbers Neil says it all mate
look at the power rating 40 easy money
chain P 10 you can't get any stronger
look at the table IQ and the wrist and
hand for Devin Lara that is the key to
this match he must expose the hand and
wrist what's going on here the phone
really as I said her you know I think
that's a little biased and I think it's
based on the fact that a lot of people
know Devin Lara from social media Dave
Chiefy is a hell you're gonna find out
all right well that's further ado let's
get the introductions from our pin
announcer Justin Roberts ladies and
gentlemen it is no time before our main
event of the evening
Los Angeles California it is now time
for our main event of the evening
a best-of-five heavyweight war between
two of the best arm wrestlers on the
planet introducing the participants
first a maximum-security corrections
officer competing out of Airy
Pennsylvania standing at 6 feet 2 inches
tall and weighing in at to 177 pounds
with a record of 32 wins and 3 losses he
is a multi-year wal champion and hammer
holder he is easy money day
[Applause]
[Music]
and his opponent a former member of the
Canadian Armed Forces competing on a big
island Ontario Canada
he says it's six feet five inches tall
and weighed in at to 168 pounds
it was the 2015 2016 and 2017 wala
heavyweight champion and one of only
four people to have won the wal hammer
on both arms ran a record of 33 wins and
four losses he is considered one of the
most charismatic arm wrestlers of all
time
No Limits David
[Music]
[Applause]
so Devin layer it up in his shoe game
here tonight Neil pad I'll show you what
it is you'd like to break my shoe right
the rear ended hese would thing is wound
tight really tight and you know what the
good that the thing is you talk about
you up you talk about you you talk about
you that's fine but the night comes when
you got to deliver on all that talk it's
now kids on who brought the talk to
reality we're gonna find out what I'll
tell you Dave Chaffee look it's started
already closing games have started
already with Dave Chaffee when he came
out from the curtain yep looked
aggressive he looked ready he's gonna
have to survive a goal utter mind game
running the gauntlet
[Applause]
but what trying to get him set
best-of-five here be very important
stages of the March I was who strap
listening in to see if I could catch any
little channels from either mama
so that solved nothing 30 seconds
expired dope all the commands will be
across to do to be fair I think he's got
a case there doesn't look like he's off
center he's just trying to keep his in
the center of the table from where he
can would cause the foul on Devon laris
aggressive individuals to combat
situation so it feels like at the moment
he's not getting a fair crack of the
whip in terms of position and typical
devil shy about walking back and down
but he needs to make sure he doesn't
burn up too much nervous energy as a
city hasn't actually achieved anything
yet in terms of gaining any kind of
fatigue level on the hand and wrist a
champion believe me that's being pulled
a little bit right here towards Dave
side close he needs to get the brakes
off her head no compromise that
ristohannah Chaffee driving Massey drive
to the center couldn't get the print
didn't look like a pinwheel Scheuer and
Chafee gets the first one Neal yeah I
don't know they look to Frank Dean this
may go to the video review so I left a
wait-and-see Hardin plays out I would
love to see that go to the square in the
era it may we very well may I'm gonna
say we are shut above the table here yes
say we don't necessarily have the best
angle on that so I'd really like to see
that should be square in the air yeah
pivotal Paul a hundred percent square in
the air for me like back now I think got
a match of this magnitude you gotta be
that's not a pin
yeah pin for me I mean looking at that I
don't see that as a pin at all arts
coming over to the review - calling that
a little bit earlier I personally don't
agree with that at all I think that will
not offend it looked like it was at
least an inch short for me that's not a
pin I don't know we as I say we are such
a Bobby let's look at the square in the
air let's look at the way all right
they're utilizing it Bart wants to see
it see that drives now this is the
pivotal moment any second now
much of the significance no pin wait for
by you Neal
bury it yes if you nobody wants to win
with a referee's decision everybody
wants to win with an arm-wrestling match
so we're back to goose eggs still on
Devon yes justice served there in many
respects and Devon did manage to
compromise Dave's hand and wrist a
little there if he could put the brakes
on Dave he knows that he has a massive
opportunity just clarifying the fault
yes one foul on Devon strap being
applied once again here their mental
approach to the game is so different
Dave Chaffee has said very little
he has Devin Lara has said a lot is into
Chapter five yep chapter five one of the
many things Devon leritz said prior to
this match he said Davis victorious in
the last two meetings he has called me
out dave has lived safely on the other
side of the bars neither a lock nor
Martin would protect him at 5:04 he has
my full attention certainly does and
closer though he may have had
the referees have got at least 20 people
here yep look like a jump start and
cherry finished it there he was off
early they're dragging each other and
it's getting a little physical oh yeah
safety with one pin down smouldering so
it is now run nothing in favor of Dave
Chaffee here with 90 seconds for these
two guys to go to their corners yeah I'm
gonna be home popular individually here
but I thought might look like a jump
start you sort of running you look a
little bit here and you go to cup Dave
Chaffee some slack whether or not I did
to change the outcome I don't know but
he certainly either anticipated the girl
very well or he moved just before he
looked like he was away early to me I'm
calling tight man back to the table I
should say is Chaffee as the monster
michael todd in his corner let's take a
listen in let's eavesdrop a little bit
here I think I'd like to listen to what
the
do you feel it went early up yeah
Devon's just as he doesn't know he's
almost finished I'm still trying to wine
this macho less he is he loves that risk
this is a man let's just we've said it
before we say it again this is unnatural
you've been saying that the last couple
days open palm Chafee with a one-nothing
lead here the best-of-five and tennis
trap just go to the strap to this point
it's not working on de visite you know I
think he's playing the game as well
these are very experienced athletes and
Dave took advantage of that last set so
fiance maybe but you know you pay your
money you take your chances couldn't get
it there couldn't get what he wanted he
needs to try and get some bullets into
Dave's hand and wrist to try and put the
brakes on because if he comes to a power
match there's only gonna be one winner
you're looking at arguably the strongest
man on the roster and Dave Chaffin for
raw power it may not be the most
technical but horsepower he's right
there
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what he was upset with me they're
trying to finish he's not been able to
do so there and this is actually good
for Devin in some respect because he
wants that horsepower to be burned to be
diminished and safety every time he
stretches open like that it's actually
good for Lehren he comes and connects
but he can't finish and Larrick staying
with it Larrick putting some bullets
into him now and this is the strategy
that he was looking for early he wants
to tired aim to make it a black hole of
attrition Dave doesn't do well here he's
a dragster
have you looked at the - it's a dragster
against a rally car right when it's on a
straight hilly bullet dragster asked the
speed right now the road is it going
Pete and Dave Chaffee he's feeling it
now Devon were pitting there he wants
you to pin himself he wants to embarrass
him the tables falling apart Devon's got
him they're talking about sportsmanship
there and yesterday he said I gotta fill
this baby's going a distance hey it's
wrong wrong now but that pin is food
look at right now Devon he's hauled it
all today though he's trying to gas that
gum out yeah and he is unafraid to do
that he wants to this man dr. Billy not
now Dave Chaffee turn to try and adjust
his game
there's gonna be a very very pivotal pin
coming up because what we're about to
see here is who took the damage in that
round the attrition there on the hand
and wrist is pretty cool and as the
match progressed you saw it was almost
like a glass of confidence and Dave
Chaffee just was emptied all over yeah
I'd love to know how much lactic acid is
in that arm and Dave Chaffee man mask
helping him out
Nevin looks pretty relaxed Ben he does
now things are even up at one 135
seconds remaining until Bart wood will
call them back to the table we look back
here final moments now this you noticed
at this point to the match again sort of
the critical element of the match was
not now it was before when Dave was
attacking when Dave was on the a side
but what I will say here is that that
point Devin could have finished their
did not even resist what Dave's doing
there he's traveling to Devon about his
lack of sportsmanship and Devon yeah
would have held him there all day yeah
he sort of wants to be what Dave and
visit he wants to be everything that
Dave said he was and Morris and look at
Dave Chaffee he is below in your hand
hard he looks like you've just come off
an 800 meter sprint struggling to get
breath
Devon Lara looks okay oh and that highly
risky sacrifice now a little bit more it
is all now and Dave Jesus you're gonna
need to go to the bank now Ben I can
tell you because we're off Route one one
here it's been an adventure to say the
least getting the strap on these two in
this match see if where it's emotions
have caused some here that emotion
wasn't what it seemed that he was trying
there to create a situation of chaos he
fries there
he likes to be in that situation he
likes to create freedom at the table
where he can move where he can utilize
that Hamlin risk strategy to burn his
opponent he knows that they chafe is
stronger but he also knows that it's
almost boxer against the function knows
that if he can put miles on Dave's
overcome then he has the advantage he
said well he's about to do so I think
DTP has tried to pull a tips move he's
dropped right now under the table
he's trying to win this with bodyweight
and devil Eric just smile at her Devin
connecting Dave's trying to come up and
engage a press he's going for it like
never before but Devin is working very
hard here believe me he's trying to call
him and he's trying to bounce Dave back
David just gave himself he needs to
watch that or big pressure there but
he's right here is the sacrifice
Devin look he's baiting it he's talking
to him three fouls and it's again for
Devin and Devin wasn't attacking back
there yeah he was letting Dave feel like
he was in the match he was letting Dave
attack and burst his energy wide open
Davis very long left now David mocking
him because he utilized mics all move
that Yahoo's move up
[Applause]
so Devin lair it went away from closing
this out in for you know both take a
90-second break here in their corners a
very ugly affair emotionally charged but
when we see this on the replay look at
the face of devil hilarity he's got a
huge smile all over it because he knows
that all the disparate elements that go
to make up Dave Chaffee weapons his
primary assault are already damaged
they're already burned and you can see
that big smile he's not trying to finish
Dave there he's trying to give him false
hope great pictures by our camera
operators standing work by them does
Devin close an out of you yes I think he
does mate I think I think right now
Devin is in a pivotal position and and
it's gonna be interesting to see how
Devin actually reacts now I really don't
feel like Dave can can take the match
from here and the living to prove me
wrong and get a fit a little bit because
then it goes the duration but I'll tell
you what it is that demeanor there from
Dave that laughing smiling joking
demeanor yeah tells a story tells a
story because he hasn't wanted to joke
there's been no playtime now but right
now he's rolled over to little and he's
shown his throat yeah Devin Lara will
jump on that yep he's a pit bull he
wants to finish and I wonder what
Devin's gonna do now he was very very
upset by the comments today of chief he
leading up to this match certainly was
Willie now revert Willie go back to
being more sporting or will he try to
embarrass Dave now because I think he's
got the ability to do that I'd love Dave
to prove me wrong but I just think he's
really struggled Dave yeah doesn't arm
wrestle well in the long drawn-out
battles it's not his game who said he's
a dragster he's meant that his whole
career
he's Dave looking to get away to get a
breather to shake that all Mountain to
Gainey's
he's sweating heavily Devon's calling
him on you've got no time yeah yeah
nominated strapped the time out and
we're going there and you know it's
actually the best chance Dave's got with
the strapping yeah he can use at least
the arm strength but I think a lot of
its good it's almost like the dragster
nose bicycle tires on all that power is
gonna be burned into the ether you can
no longer get it down drive it's devil
or its world never now more relaxed he's
not fighting with the referees he feels
like he's in a position where he doesn't
need to do that he can get what he needs
in the match he's calm now he created
the situation that he could thrive in he
created a situation that allowed him to
burnout Dave Chaffee and now he's calm
he's almost cocky there will be millions
and but I think he may just make this a
very long horn about their safety trying
to stay alive huge drive for an inmate
but if you look at Devon's face all that
panic
stop it on Devon Springs actually yeah
yes to gain position yeah that's not
intentionally stood to gain ask Devon
talking to you
[Applause]
adjust this position very very oddly
much to watch didn't allow deaden the
opportunity to pin him he looked for the
way out unfold himself out of the match
yeah unfortunate ending for Chafee Devin
Lehren wins it 3-1 after words had been
exchanged for the last few weeks turned
into a disappointingly ugly affair at
the table mate but yeah when you look at
that replay as soon as the match started
and Devin sacrificed that hand and wrist
Dave was in a world of trouble and when
you're in that situation it's very very
hard to get back and Devin started to
work he's mind they're starting to
embarrass him this is a proud man he
didn't want that and he looked for the
way out and found it he did down a
Jason's on Fisher standing by with Dave
JP easy money Dave Chaffee you guys put
on a show here tonight this is the first
time that Devin was able to beat you
what was the difference here tonight he
came in prepared fired up I did too he
liked it he came in real strong powerful
he was better tonight I give him credit
bad dude right there well speaking of
bad dude you you guys have shared some
bad words before this I mean there's
been a lot of talk how much was that in
your head and how much were you trying
to get in his head tonight before this
match it's a little ball that fired me
up the stuff I said fired him up but
we're friends after the table now so
it's all good all right well what's next
for you easy money Dave Chaffee you're
still one of the best to ever do it
we'll see what happens hopefully I get
another call from WL maybe September who
knows we'll see all right well everyone
give it up one more time for Dave
Chaffee easy money
and keep it going for your Victor here
tonight no limits
Devon Lehren hey Devon it was that was
not easy at all I mean you are soaking
wet you are dripping in sweat how hard
did you have to work for this victory
here tonight ah you know David he's
stronger he just stays he's stronger I
had to I had to use all the ugliness
that arm wrestling has to offer
all right this sport you got to be
willing to put it all out there you got
to be willing to go to the line okay
I'm I'm willing to go all the way and
this match is like this matches it was
everything for me it's I'm speechless
how you had never beaten Dave Chaffee
before in your entire career you've done
so much you've accomplished so much what
does this win here tonight mean to you
Dave Chaffee all around the world is
recognized Dave Chaffee has gone to
Europe he's beaten the top guys I just
recently went to Europe and faced one of
the strongest men in the world Dennis
the plank off and like most you know I
got killed Dave dave has a win on Dennis
so for me this is just a step closer to
where I want to be well like I said to
easy money there was a lot of talk
before this match he said that you don't
respect your opponents you try to get in
their head but I hear a lot of respect
for Dave Chaffee after this match coming
from you well you know I love this sport
I love I love the feelings that it gives
me today in this life you know you can
get material wealth you can get all
sorts of things but the real treasure I
think is these feelings and to me this
is a feeling I'll treasure forever
that's amazing well this is a feeling I
think we all will treasure forever thank
you for putting on a great show tonight
you gave your all and we appreciate it
that was an amazing match thanks wel
thanks Dave Chaffee see you guys soon
but this is not the end my friends
because we got another match coming up
next month I cannot wait Ben Neil what a
night it was thank you so much Jason
we'll be in Tulsa on August the 15th
tonight's broadcast and part presented
by Bleacher Report live great to have be
our live as a part of the wal and
jerrican aret and Todd Hutchings
tonzilla coming up on the 15th
wal five all five will be the main event
Neil the unstoppable force versus the
immovable object what's at March can't
wait to see it but what about tonight
then it's starting with the Jamie
Sheldon show and the intensity from the
Australian Ryan Bowen was something to
behold we have a new lady in town her in
the air his mauling Kleinschmidt she
arrived with a bang mat mask back on
track the wild horse is off the scale
and I'll tell you what you could hear
the genuine emotion yeah seven Lauren
could it was intense great night for
Neil pick up Jason's own Fisher Justin
Roberts Warren picks Steve Kaplan our
executive producer my name is Ben Holden
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time on VR live
[Music]